[MUSIC PLAYING]
MORGAN MCLEAN: My
name is Morgan McLean.
I'm a product manager at Google.
In particular, I'm the product
manager of our Stackdriver APM
software and OpenCensus
For those who aren't aware,
our Stackdriver APM
software is composed
of Stackdriver Trace,
Stackdriver Debugger,
and Stackdriver Profiler.
I'm going to talk about
both of those things
today, so Stackdriver
and OpenCensus.
I've actually divided the talk,
pretty deliberately, into two.
So we're spending the
first half on Stackdriver
and the second
half on OpenCensus.
OpenCensus is an open source
project that we collaborate on
with a number of other
vendors, so I kind of
wanted to delineate,
put a nice sort
of separation between these.
A lot of the concepts
will be the same.
And certainly we'll be doing
different demonstrations
of both, but just
keep that in mind
as we go through, that the
talk is sort of divided in two.
So like I said, we're
starting with part one, which
is about how we actually do
observability and optimization
and troubleshooting for
app development at Google.
And this ties to
the Stackdriver.
So I know the term observability
is being thrown around a lot
at conferences, on the
internet, everywhere recently.
You know, you can look back
at a number of great talks,
like certainly one, I
think, that Adrian Cole
did a few years ago called
"Observability Three
Ways," where he talked about
tracing, logs analysis,
and metrics.
And to be clear, that's
a really great way
to approach the problem.
But I suspect that thinking
about observability
in terms of the tools that
we use to analyze it probably
isn't quite as useful
as actually talking
about the concepts that
we want to talk about,
And, indeed, talking
about what we can actually
achieve by being able to observe
our application operates.
So when we think of Google
st Google observability,
we think of actual
scenarios that engineers
have to adapt to everyday.
When someone searches
for cat pictures,
what systems are impacted or
why are some requests slow?
Will the system scale if
we get a lot more users?
And this is where
observability, the concepts
behind observability
give us a lot of--
are able to answer these
questions that we have.
So in practice, we
find observability
means a couple of things.
It means setting expectations.
So you would have
heard, I think,
in this morning's keynote, a
lot about SLO or SLI monitoring.
And that's what we use
at Google to actually set
expectations for how a
service should perform.
Right, we set actual
standards for,
the latency given a certain
amount of usage should be such.
There error budget should
be this other thing.
And so if you're not able
to set those expectations,
it becomes difficult
when looking
at the service's
performance to understand
if it's operating as it should.
The next is context,
so understanding
what a service actually does.
If you're an
engineer and you work
on a service that's 5 or
10 or even 50 layers down
in the stack, you need to
understand those interactions
all around you.
Often it's that's difficult,
particularly at organizations
where they don't
have an automated
way of understanding how
these services are supposed
to interact.
Right, I'm sure we've all
worked in organizations where
you might have 5, 10, 20, 50
microservices or more, where
you'll have someone
who doesn't have
that organizational
knowledge come in
and spend a lot of time
just understanding like,
oh, I work on this
little component
of the e-commerce system, but
I don't understand how that
operates with everything else.
And in order to debug
problems at scale,
you would need that context.
Next is status.
This is probably the most
simple out of these concepts.
This is just understanding,
is my service is up?
Is it down?
How is it performing?
What's the resource
consumption look like?
What's the current latency?
And finally, there's one concept
that often gets forgotten.
That's actually performing
root cause analysis.
So it's fine to have
the first three things,
but when you actually have
a problem in production,
you need to have the tools
available to actually solve
that problem.
It's fine to know
that a service is down
and, if you follow the
other observability concepts
and have great
tooling, to understand
which service is dying.
But if you don't have the tools
to fix it or understand what
in the code is actually
broken, you still
haven't solved the problem.
So none of this is new, right?
This is part of, I think, a
broader journey that developers
have been on for years, where
if you look at client app
development, whether that's
applications for desktops
or laptops or phones or video
game consoles or whatever,
there's been a lot of great
tools for this for years.
Right, think of stack
traces, whenever
you have an unhandled
exception running on your Mac
or on Windows.
Right, think of local debuggers,
local profiling tools.
All of these have
existed for a long time.
Where we've
struggled is actually
adapting these same techniques
to distributed systems
development.
Because it becomes a
lot more difficult,
where you can no longer
just attach a debugger
to a single system to
solve an issue because that
might have impacts on
other users of that system.
And you might not
even know which system
you need to attach it to.
And so that's
really the struggle
that a lot of developers
have been going through
for the last 10 years, as we
shift a lot of our computing
workloads from client
applications up to the cloud
or up to running on platforms
that you might not even be
able to gain much insight into.
So that was a bit
of a long prologue,
but you were promised something
about observability at Google.
So let's talk about that.
So Google runs at
pretty extreme scale.
That shouldn't be a
surprise to anyone.
And over the past
few decades, we've
had to invent new
technologies and tools
in order to scale and survive.
There's a reason that, when your
internet connection is flaky,
people go to Google.com
to actually see
if the internet is up.
And if it's not, if
Google.com doesn't respond,
they tend to assume that just
their network connection is
flaky.
A lot of this is due to our
platform and our people,
but it's also due
to the tools that we
have in order to gain
insight and to be
able to fix our systems.
So I'm going to start
by just giving you
a very brief introduction
to the services
available at Google
and the platform.
So you've probably heard
about things like Borg.
Borg is our container
scheduling-- or container
orchestration service.
This is basically what
Kubernetes is based on.
And certainly at
Google you may have
heard of things like Stubby.
This is effectively an
internationalized version
of gRPC and some other tools--
and then storage services like
Spanner, Bigtable, and others.
The layer that we've
talked about a lot less
is for out instrumentation
and tooling.
So for instrumentation,
all services at Google
are instrumented with
something called Census.
These are a set
of libraries that
are baked into Stubby
and baked into some
of our other technologies
that automatically
capture traces and app-level
metrics of an application.
So you'll get
distributed traces,
much like you would see
in Stackdriver Trace,
through a backend
that we call Dapper,
which you can see there.
But you'll also get
metrics for things
like application latency, the
queue length of certain RPCs,
and so on.
And you get this
as the developers
for free out of the box.
You create a new service,
Census is already there.
It's already capturing this.
And for profiling, we have
tools like Google-Wide Profiling
and pprof that
capture information.
And we've also got a production
debugger called the Borg
Debugger and so we've
made a lot of investments
in instrumentation to ensure
that when you build a service
inside of Google you get all
of this automatically for free.
You don't have to go reinvent
the wheel every time.
Indeed, you typically don't
even need to add a library.
It just [SNAPS FINGERS]
works out of the box
it's really nice.
For tooling and
analysis of this data,
we have a number
of other backends.
So Monarch is where we
capture and aggregate
stats and analyze them.
Dapper, which I
mentioned before,
is our distributed
tracing system.
We have pprof for profiling.
And, like I mentioned
before, we the Borg Debugger.
And I'm showing you this
because, in a few minutes,
we're going to talk
about the external story.
And we're going to replace a
lot of technology that you know
and some that you might not.
So let's talk about how we walk
through a scenario at Google,
for example, reducing the
latency of an application.
So the first step is
actually understanding
if a service is operating
more slowly than expected.
So as I mentioned
in the beginning,
we have SLOs and SLIs,
and basically descriptions
of a service that
tell us how we expect
it to operate in production.
And so at Google,
to launch a service,
you need to define those.
And so you can set
up alerts to find out
when your application has
breached those barriers.
The next is Triage.
So if you're trying to
analyze latency over time,
you need to create and
store latency metrics
for all our PCs.
I talked about Census
and Monarch and Dapper,
and that's how we do
that inside of Google.
And so that's always
running on all services.
So you can jump back in
time and actually see
how your service is
performing and how
that performance may have
degraded or gotten better
over time.
And then you need to be able to
narrow that down and determine
the approximate
cause of latency.
So at Google you might
have requests that hop
through tens or even maybe
thousands of microservices.
The first job is just finding
out which layer down the stack
is actually slowing things down.
Generally at that scale it's
unlikely that everything has
slowed down-- though if it
has, that's also an interesting
development--
so you can use tracing
to actually find out
where it's gotten slow.
And finally, you need to go
in and solve the problem.
This involves actually
deploying code
or deploying configuration.
And so this can be achieved
by creating things like custom
trace segments and annotations
in your traces or logs,
or continuously profiling
your running code.
And I talked about pprof before.
That's our solution for that.
The other major
scenario we see is
resolving errors in production.
So we talked about latency.
Now this is when you actually
have some kind of error,
whether that's an
unhandled exception that's
causing sporadic
problems for a person,
or for some of your
users, to a total outage.
So the first, just like
before is getting notified.
And instead of latency
budgets, in this case,
we have an error budget.
Right?
And so just like those latency--
just like SLO or SLI
for errors, we'll
fire an alert when
those are not met.
Then you want to be
able to do triage,
so jumping into
metrics analysis,
logs analysis, or distributed
tracing to find out
the source of your error.
Once again, when you're
in that scenario where
you have tens, hundreds, or
thousands of microservices
interacting, you need
to find out which one
or which change to
a single service
actually caused that problem.
And then eventually
you need to-- you
want to go and find out
the actual code that's
causing a problem.
Offline debugging at Google
is effectively not really
an option.
You might not be able
to reproduce something.
It's very difficult to set up a
test environment for something
that involves like
tens or hundreds
or thousands of services.
That's effectively impossible.
And so we needed to invent
safe production debugging.
And that's the Borg Debugger
that I mentioned earlier.
We finally have one
additional scenario.
And this is just generally
wanting to reduce your costs
and optimize code.
This is one that you
might not hear about as
often at other firms.
It might not be--
certainly in my
development career,
it's not a scenario
that came up as often.
But for our users and
certainly at Google,
when we have all these data
centers everywhere chugging
away, it's really
important that we're
able to reduce the
cost in those, right?
If you think of being
able to reduce your CPU
consumption by 1%, 5%, 10%,
or more, at that scale,
this is huge amounts of
money that you're saving.
And it becomes really,
really important the more
your business grows.
And so when we want
to reduce our costs,
there's two ways
we can go about it.
The first is just going
through distributed traces
and finding services
that are heavily
impacted by single requests.
Right?
So if it turns out that doing
a search to a Google search,
or maybe checking your
Gmail or something,
goes and hits like tens or
thousands of disks, spindles,
or something like
that, that might not be
the most well-optimized query.
If you have a single
small request that's
fanning out across
your entire network
and grabbing data
from various systems
and things aren't cached well,
that's probably a problem.
But the next is actually digging
into your service's code.
So you can also have
situations where
a single service is performing
poorly, and as a result,
you're needing to scale it
out a lot more widely than you
expected.
And we've seen this internally
as well as with our customers.
And in that case,
continuous profiling.
So I talked a little
bit about pprof before.
But continuously profiling the
application, so as an engineer,
you can go and look at
how the code is actually
executed for that app.
It's really powerful.
So you can find out if there's
some sort of contention going
on, or just if
you're burning way
more CPU cycles on something
than you think you should.
And so I just want to hit on
some of these core concepts
again.
I apologize just in general
if this seems a little vague.
We're going to go into
a very concrete example
in a few minutes.
But the core
concepts we have here
are SLOs and metrics, so
actually setting expectations
for a service's
performance, whether that's
latency or errors; traces
and log correlation,
so using distributed
traces or basically
being able to map the
context of a request
and see how that fans out
across services, both to reduce
those services' latency or to
out where a problem might be
caused; and finally continuously
debugging and profiling
an application.
Debugging and
profiling in production
are less common concepts.
I'm sure a number
of you have heard
of distributed tracing before.
Certainly I would
expect everyone here
knows about distributed metrics
and certainly distributed logs.
But doing this for
profiling and debugging
are rather new concepts.
And we've got these
in a pretty nice demo.
And these are things we
do at Google every day.
So to hit on that point that
I opened with, traces, logs,
metrics, profile,
everything else,
these are not observability.
These are the tools that we
use to achieve observability.
The more of these
that you build,
the more you're able
to actually understand
how a series of systems
perform in real life.
And also you're better
able to fix them.
Certainly, the term
observability will be evolving.
Certainly the four or five
tools that I've introduced
here are not going to be
end-state that will be in one
or two or three years from now.
More and more will be invented.
And that's just going to add
to people's ability to observe
and debug their
running applications.
So I've talked a bit about
how we do this at Google.
And for various reasons,
I can't necessarily
give you a live
demo of the tools
we have inside the company.
But what I can do is
talk about the tools
that we make
available externally.
And as of today, now that
we've had some recent launches,
those actually map
pretty well between what
we make available to GCP
developers, or really
developers anywhere, and what
we have inside the company.
So that's what I'm
going to demonstrate.
So before I do that, I
gave you this slide before,
the tools inside of Google.
I'm now going to show you
those tools outside of Google.
So people here, externally,
are not using things like Borg.
You're using Kubernetes.
You're using containers
running on other container
orchestration systems.
You're using virtual machines,
platforms as a service,
functions as a service.
For RPCs, you're
typically using a mix
of HTTP gRPC, maybe sidecars
like Envoy or maybe other RPC
systems.
For storage, when we
talk to customers,
they use MySQL, MongoDB,
various hosted options,
whether that's data store
or things from other cloud
vendors.
For instrumentation,
there's been
a lot of interesting
developments
in the space recently.
Certainly there's OpenCensus,
which we developed and I'm
spending the second
half of this talk on,
for metrics and traces.
But there are also
existing systems, right?
A lot of people
here probably are
very familiar with
using Prometheus
for collecting metrics
from their applications.
And certainly for
distributed tracing,
Zipkin is incredibly popular
and includes its own client
libraries.
And so we see clients who are
already using those today.
For profiling and
debugging, those
are still a little more unique.
These are concepts that I
suspect were effectively
invented at Google.
And so our offerings in this
space are relatively unique,
but we offer those as well.
And finally for logs,
I wrote FluentD here.
There's obviously a ton
of things in this space.
And for tooling, sort of
the crux of this talk,
we have the tools that we offer.
So for metrics, we have
Stackdriver Monitoring,
which people will be
pretty familiar with.
It's a startup acquired by
Google a number of years ago.
And it's the brand we use
for our monitoring software.
We also offer Stackdriver Trace,
Profiler, Debugger, Stackdriver
Logging, which completes that
list of observability tools
that exist at Google,
except now they're
available to our customers.
I'm just going to skip ahead.
So I'm going to skip
all the way to the demo.
So we have here an application
called Hipster Shop.
So anyone who went to
the keynote this morning
would have seen this
for the SDO keynote.
It's this demo app that we
created to show off various GCP
features.
And it emulates an
e-commerce system.
It's written across
eight separate services,
I think three or four of
which are written in Go,
two of which are
written in Python,
two or three are
written and Node.js,
and one of them is
written in .NET Core.
They're all running
on Kubernetes.
In fact, they're running on GKE.
There's no special sauce here.
This is using stuff
that's been available
for the last year or so.
Hipster Shop, this
version of Hipster Shop,
unlike the one that you saw
this morning, is really slow.
We did a bit of work to it.
We ensured that it
takes basically forever
to load a page.
And even once you load it, when
you add an item to your cart,
it is unbearably slow.
And this is a great example
of a web application
where, if you ship this and told
people to go buy stuff here,
you'd be losing a ton of your
customers right off the bat
because it's just so
ridiculously slow.
And the challenge is,
it's consistently slow.
So if we look at
metrics, for example--
I think this is the right one.
And of course it unloaded.
If we look at metrics,
once they actually load,
we will see that--
that scrolls.
Go back to Trace--
you would have seen that
the services were basically
consistently slow.
Everything has slowed
down in this application.
So even looking at distributed
metrics, where you've
captured latency from
every node of the system,
whether it's the catalog
service or the front end
service or others,
they're all equally slow.
And so metrics
aren't really going
to be able to help you to
diagnose what the problem is.
So instead we can jump
to Stackdriver Trace.
So Stackdriver Trace is a
distributed tracing solution.
For those who don't know
what distributed tracing is,
we're able to capture
a request as it comes
into your first front
end edge services,
and then we track that request
as it goes to any subservices
as it propagates.
So in this case, for example,
it hops from the cart endpoint,
goes to the currency service,
then hot to the cart service,
then to recommendations,
and then
finally several times to
the product catalog service,
then to shipping,
currency, and so on.
And so we can see
this request as it
bounces around the application.
We can see two
things in particular
that are probably really bad.
The first is it goes to
the catalog service a lot.
So when we're getting
details on a single product,
it doesn't really make sense
that we would continually
call the product catalog
database to find out
details about that product.
That should be cached or,
frankly, it's probably just
poorly written.
It is.
It's poorly written, and
it's just calling it way too
many times instead
of just keeping
the data in memory somewhere.
And so this sounds like maybe
a somewhat contrived example,
but this is the sort of thing
that we see with our customers.
And certainly I've seen
myself as an engineer, where
when you don't have
these tools to understand
how your application works,
when you're not tracking how
these requests
function, you might not
notice that when someone--
when one engineer
was writing something
and needed more data
from the catalog,
they just made another call.
And this adds up
over time, and you
get these sort of monstrous webs
of application topology in ways
that no one expected
to actually function.
And that's why
you have slowness.
[AUDIO OUT]
--even if we had a single call
to the product catalog service,
most of these are taking
well over a second.
This one takes
basically 1.6 seconds.
And so the web application
would still be too slow.
We're going to dig
into the second case.
We already know what the
problem is in the first case.
We know that we need to
reduce the number of calls.
But the second case is actually
the harder one to debug,
where the individual calls
are really, really slow.
And distributed
tracing helps a bit.
We know that the
calls to the catalog
are causing the slowdown.
That's already taken us through
our first level of triage that
metrics didn't.
But unless you added a ton of
custom spans to this trace,
you're not going to
know why it's slow.
And to understand
that we're going
to go to Stackdriver Debugger--
or sorry, Stackdriver Profiler.
Stackdriver Profiler is a
continuous production profiler.
What that means is
that it's always
running in the background,
on and off, so to you
as the developer, it's
effectively always running.
It turns itself on and
off at various points
to capture profilers--
or capture profiles.
And it has effectively
no performance impact.
That is also true for
Trace and Debugger,
but unlike most
production profilers,
you can leave this one.
You can effectively just turn
it on, set it, and forget it.
You don't have to
worry about running it
for 15-minute sessions
or something like that.
You don't have to worry about
it slowing down your app.
Profiler captures
a number of things.
Right now we're looking
at the heap view.
So we're capturing the memory
consumption of every function
running on this service.
We can also look
at CPU consumption.
We can also look at how
threads are interacting.
Profiler is great
because it runs
on all of the instances
of your service.
So just like Trace,
just like Debugger,
you don't have to point it
at a particular instance.
You don't turn it on a
single instance or some kind
of canary instance.
You simply link it to
your code, turn it on,
and it's running across
all of the instances.
And you're going to see
performance data captured
from all of them.
This is the heap view.
We don't see anything
quite too exciting here.
We can look for the get product
endpoint, which from the trace
was shown to be the
slow one, or rather the
get product gRPC
method, which was shown
to be slow from the trace.
But this is only
consuming 12 and 1/2%
of the application's
total memory.
And that's still
only about-- what?--
254 kilobytes.
So this is clearly not the
source of our problems.
But when we jump to
CPU consumption--
just going to take
a swig of my water--
when we jump to
CPU consumption, we
see that things are pretty bad.
So this is the get
product endpoint.
It alone is
consuming roughly 93%
of this application's CPU,
just this one function.
And given that
I've played around
with the catalog
service's code, I
know that this shouldn't
be the case, right?
It has a number of
gRPC endpoints--
or rather gRPC server methods--
that handle traffic.
It doesn't makes sense that get
product is using so much CPU.
But when we look down
on this icicle graph--
and this icicle graph shows
consumption on the horizontal
axis, and on the vertical
axis, we're showing how these
functions actually
call each other--
we can see that this calls a
method called Parse Catalog.
And Parse Catalog is effectively
consuming the same amount
of CPU as its parent function.
So this is where all
the time is spent.
And this is where you're both
burning money and burning time.
And this seems bad.
So next we're actually
going to jump to the code.
This view here is in
Cloud Source Repositories,
though the code for
this application
is actually stored on GitHub.
The distinction between
those is kind of
irrelevant for this demo.
But we're actually
jumping to the code,
and we can see we're
basically just deserializing
a bunch of JSON.
So what we've already learned
from Trace and Profiler
in a few minutes is that
the catalog is slow,
or rather requests to
the website are slow.
They're slow because
the catalog is slow.
And the catalog is slow
because this Parse Catalog
method is spending all of
its time deserializing JSON.
And that's probably bad.
And so, as a developer,
we've learned something
that otherwise might be very
difficult to understand,
or we would only
know because we have
a lot of existing knowledge
of how the system operates.
But we've gone through
this in the way
that a new developer could go
through it relatively quickly.
And so Trace and,
in turn, Profiler
have helped us solve
this performance problem
quickly and reliably.
And we can apply this to
other parts of the system.
Next I'm going to show
you Stackdriver Debugger.
In this case, we
don't have an error
that we've sort of had time
to code into the application
to debug, so I'm just
going to give you
a demonstration of debugger
and show you why it's useful.
So Stackdriver Debugger,
as I mentioned,
is a production debugger.
It effectively lets you set
breakpoints in production that
don't halt customer queries.
This is pretty magical.
This is one of the things
that when we show it off
at our booth or at
demos like this,
we get initially a bit of
skepticism from viewers
saying, "you can't do that.
That's not possible."
But we can.
And so we present everything
in this really nice
IDE-like interface.
It's not wildly different
than Visual Studio
Code, or IntelliJ, or others.
And you can click in the
gutter and set a thing
that looks like a breakpoint.
But what we're doing
here is setting something
that we call a snapshot.
And a snapshot is
effectively a breakpoint,
but we don't halt execution.
So execution flows
right through it.
But we do capture
the local variables.
And we do capture
the stack trace.
And just like a
traditional debugger,
you can use conditions
and expressions.
I'm not going to
demonstrate those today,
but it's got basically
the same functionality
that you would expect when
you're debugging something
locally on your laptop
or on your desktop.
And so I'll show that
to you right now.
We've got a load test running
against this application.
And so I don't even
have to open the app
to capture data from it.
But if we put a snapshot
right here, for example--
delete that existing one--
we can see how the
code executes inside
of this convert function.
This convert function is
inside of the currency service.
The currency service will
convert in the storefront.
The storefront lets you
convert from US dollars
to euros to yen,
and that's performed
by this particular service.
Aaa, where did it go?
There is it.
And so the snapshot
that we laid down
has now been
captured at line 123.
And we can see the
various objects and things
that were captured from it.
And so, for example,
if we wanted
to see the current-- if
there was some kind of issue
of currency conversion, or we
thought the wrong rates were
being used, and we were
looking at the input
and everything seemed right,
we could actually go in here
and jump to the currency
conversion rates that
are being stored in
memory, in the service,
in production right now.
And so we could very
quickly be able to decide
if the rates that are
being stored are wrong
or if there is some other
kind of problem occurring.
Similarly, we can look at
any of the objects here.
We can also jump
through the call stack
and capture the local
variables captured
in each of those frames.
So it's just the
exact same power
you would expect from
a local debugger,
except it's running
live in production
and will not affect anything.
So it's really, really powerful.
We use the same thing
at Google with a tool
called Borg Debugger
that's basically the same.
It's really, really nice for
solving rare production issues.
So I'm just going to sort
of double click on some
of the key benefits that we saw.
So Stackdriver Debugger
snapshots, as well as
a feature in Debugger
called log points that
allows you to push out log
statements to your application
instantly without
redeploying it,
remove a ton of deployment
steps doing root cause analysis.
Today, if you're
developing on Kubernetes
or some kind of
distributed system,
and you're often in the
production environment, where
it's either difficult
or just impossible
to attach a debugger, you would
often solve problems like this
by adding log
statements to your code.
Whenever you have
some kind of error,
you add a bunch
of log statements
to your code to flush
out how it's operating
and add things to logs, redeploy
your app with the error still
in tow because you don't know
what the actual error is caused
by.
That can take a while.
Then you get to read the
logs, using your logging tool,
and find out if the system is
functioning the way you expect
or maybe get some insight
into what the error is.
Maybe you found it.
Maybe you need to add
more log statements.
So you go through
typically a couple
of iteration cycles
of deploying things
to production, which is
painful and slow and bad
for your customers.
With snapshots and
then log points,
which allow you to just added
those log statements if you
want the firehose view, you
can do that [SNAPS FINGERS]
instantly, which is
really, really powerful.
And this is why we developed
Debugger inside of Google.
And this is why we use
it so often, including
some of our biggest names.
Next we had a
Stackdriver Profiler.
So Profiler operates
at extreme scale.
But unlike most
profilers, and certainly
unlike most
production profilers,
has effectively no
performance impact.
It's also not limited to
analyzing single transactions.
It gives you that
continuous flame graph
view for how your application
has been running in production.
So it gives you great
insight into the amount
of CPU used by each
function in your code
as well as the
amount of heap use.
And you can also look
at threads in contention
and other things like that.
And so it gives you
a lot of visibility
into how your core code is
running that you wouldn't have
without a tool like Profiler.
In particular, the heap view
is really useful for detecting
things like slow memory leaks.
Profiler, in
addition to give you
that understanding of
how your code operates,
is a powerful
cost-reduction tool.
So in the private
alpha for Profiler,
we had a number of customers
come back to us and say,
with about one
hour of time, they
shave 10% off their CPU
bill, off their compute bill.
Depending on your
scale, that might just
be a small amount of
money and something
that doesn't really
interest you.
But once you start
running a lot of nodes
and your monthly compute
bill is fairly high,
this is really
tangible money that you
can save with a very
small amount of time.
Additionally-- and I'll
get into this in a minute--
we had some larger customers
who were fighting performance
problems with some
of their services
that they were having to scale
way beyond what they thought
was needed.
And with Profiler,
they were able to get
back to their expected scale
by finding, in particular,
areas of high CPU consumption
that they didn't expect.
Finally I showed you
Stackdriver Trace.
Tracing is finally becoming a
much more popular and much more
well understood thing amongst
the development community,
which is awesome.
But tracing tools
tend to either be
expensive or difficult
to adopt these days.
They are certainly
open source options.
Zipkin and Jaeger are great.
But you have to go and
manage them yourself,
and spin up the Ms,
and certainly manage
the storage for them, which
can be annoying or sometimes
expensive.
There are also paid
options in the space.
They also tend to be
relatively pricey.
Stackdriver Trace is
neither of those things.
It is simple, easy to get
started with, and incredibly
cheap.
So I mentioned a
Profiler success story.
So Snapchat-- you know, it
wouldn't be talk at NEXT
without mentioning Snapchat.
Snapchat was one of
the alpha customers
for Stackdriver Profiler along
with a couple of other marquee
customers.
They used it to find
some performance issues
that they hadn't been able
to discover previously.
They left us this
very nice quote
about it being able to pinpoint
big consumers of CPU time,
and at snapscale,
certainly very large.
They were able to both
reduce their spend
on a number of
services and increase
their overall performance.
So for them it was
incredibly powerful.
We had similar stories come
from a number of our other alpha
clients as well as.
Certainly now that Profiler
has going to public beta,
we've had even more.
So that wraps up our
tour, our whirlwind tour
of Stackdriver's APM tools.
I didn't do a demo of things
like Stackdriver Monitoring
or Stackdriver's new
Kubernetes monitoring tools.
There are a number of other
talks happening on those.
But what I really
wanted to show is
how these same workflows that
we have at Google to both reduce
latency for applications
as well as find
the cause of errors,
how you can apply those
at your own companies.
Over the years and
in the coming years,
we're going to have even
more launching in this space.
But even today,
we've externalized
enough of our
application tooling,
or enough of our
developer tooling,
that external developers
can effectively
go through the same workflows
as us, which is awesome.
There was one last thing
I wanted to touch on.
So Stackdriver's APM
tools have no limitations
on where they can be used.
So if you have hybrid
cloud applications, things
that are running on premises,
things that are running
on your laptop even,
there's no restriction
on where the applications
that are being instrumented,
where they're running.
And so there's no requirement to
only use this on GCP resources.
And that's even with
the pricing plans.
So Stackdriver Profiler,
Stackdriver Debugger
are currently free.
Stackdriver Trace has a
pretty generous free tier,
and then is a paid tier
above that that's coming
into effect in September.
But this is all the
same, regardless of where
your applications are running.
And we think it's a really
competitive offering.
If you have stuff that's
running just on another cloud,
we would love for
you to use our tools.
I would be awesome.
And we think you'll get
a lot of value out of it.
So I promised this talk would
be divided into two parts.
The second part is
about OpenCensus.
So to give you a bit
of an introduction,
OpenCensus is an
instrumentation project
that we undertook
roughly about a year
and a half ago,
maybe two years ago.
And it's basically
we've been trying
to work with other vendors so
that we can get better tracing
and metrics instrumentation for
our tools and for their tools.
For those who aren't as familiar
with distributed tracing,
one of the biggest
challenges of the space,
for vendors, for developers,
for everyone else,
is getting traces to come out
of their apps automatically.
So I mentioned before that
at Google, with Dapper,
we're able to do this.
And it's really powerful.
It helps us understand how our
apps are distributed as well
as debug problems.
But we can do that
because we're running
a custom version of the JVM.
We have our own RPC library.
And so we do a lot of things
under the hood to enable this
that external developers can't.
Most shops aren't going to
go modify the JVM extensively
to go do things that they want.
They're not going to go
build their own RPC system.
And so with OpenCensus,
we're trying
to make this ubiquitous to
developers outside the company
as it is to Googlers.
And to do this we
need to go and build
integrations of every single
thing that you have that
sends and receives
an RPC, or anything
that really does a
slow-running transaction.
So where we and other
vendors have struggled
in the past has been that you
need to build integrations
across every language for HTTP,
other RPC libraries, storage
client libraries,
things for some kind
of slow-running process that
runs on each machine for things
like Kafka, for basically
any sort of client library
or anything you interact
with from tens or hundreds
of vendors.
And it's really slow and
really painful to build these.
And so we thought,
"well that's silly."
So with OpenCensus,
we've gone together--
and I'll have a list
of vendors in a minute.
But we've actually partnered up
with a number of other vendors
in this space to go
build those integrations,
so you can automatically
get traces and metrics out
of your app, and then do some
basic analysis on top of those.
And so it makes
it, as a developer,
it makes it really easy to
get started with these tools,
whether that's with Stackdriver
APM, or Stackdriver Monitoring,
or with other
solutions like Datadog,
or SolarWinds, or a number
of our other partners.
So back to the
demo app, and we're
going to do another
demo of OpenCensus.
But this is sort of--
there's no lines
connecting anything,
but this is roughly the
structure of that Hipster Shop
demo.
So it's got a frontend
service, email service,
currency service, and others.
And as I mentioned before,
they're written in Go,
Python Node.js and C#.
I listed a database here.
The demo that we're using
just uses an in-memory data--
like just basically
just has a big object
in memory as its database.
But they Hipster Shop demo,
once it's published externally,
I think it's going to connect
to some kind of SQL database.
And so just like any other
customer application,
you have to have integrations
for all these things, right?
Even if you're
using HTTP and gRPC,
you need to go build
integrations for HTTP
and gRPC across every language.
If that database
there is MongoDB
or some kind of SQL
database or something else,
in order to get traces and
metrics from interactions
with it, we need to go
build those integrations.
This is, again, just the problem
that OpenCensus is a solving.
I'm sure a number of you
from larger, older companies
can attest to,
you'll have services
running in probably
five plus languages,
using 10 to 20 different
storage technologies that
communicate to each other
using various different RPC
frameworks.
The real world out
there is a mess.
Software is developed over
a very long period of time.
Technologies change.
Old code doesn't
necessarily get deleted.
And so in order to make
all these things automatic,
we need to do a lot
of work to actually
make traces and metric show up.
So to come back to
what OpenCensus is,
OpenCensus is a
collection of libraries
that we publish on
a per-language basis
to collect traces and metrics.
We have support for--
and I'll get to the
full list in a minute,
but we're targeting support
for Java, Go Node, .NET, Ruby,
Python, PHP and C++.
So it's a list of
eight languages.
The OpenCensus libraries
for each language
have sort of three
layers to them.
They have the
instrumentation layer,
so that's the things that
I was discussing earlier,
the automatic plug-ins for
various storage frameworks,
the RPC frameworks,
basically anything
you want to capture a
trace or metric from.
They have the APIs.
So as a developer, you can
manually interact with those.
You can create your
own custom metrics.
You can change the
metrics that are
being automatically collected.
You can add
annotations to traces.
You can change the trace
sampling policy and so on.
And finally, the
reason that we've
been working with other vendors
is this concept of exporters.
So exporters are these really
small lightweight pieces
of code that allow you to
send the data collected
by OpenCensus to your
backend of choice.
One of those backends
is Stackdriver.
One of those backends is just
writing everything out to logs.
But you can also
send it to backends
like Datadog and SolarWinds
and Instana and a number
of other vendors in this space.
And the nice thing
about OpenCensus
is that the exporters are
really small amounts of code.
Like if you wanted to
support some new backend,
you don't have to go
reimplement the tracer
and reimplement how
sampling works or context
propagation for tracing, like
any of these really complicated
things.
You just write a
bit of code that
translates the data that
OpenCensus has in memory
to the format you expect and
send and RPC to your backend.
So that's really, really simple.
And our goal with OpenCensus
right from the beginning
is to be able to include
as much functionality out
of the box as possible.
The scenario we want
for most developers is
you link an OpenCensus library
to your app, traces and metrics
come out.
That's it.
You choose an exporter , then
traces and metrics come out
and get sent to your backend.
We don't want developers to be
sitting there plumbing things
and gluing things together.
It's really painful.
It means that they're not
going to use those tools.
And quite frankly,
as a company that's
in the business of
selling more and more
distributed systems through
technologies like Kubernetes,
we want to make this
as easy as possible.
That's why we invest
in OpenCensus.
So as I mentioned
before, we have
support for a number of
languages and integrations
and exporter.
Right now we have really great
support for Java, C++ and Go.
For Ruby, Python,
and PHP, the tracing
is in a production-ready state.
And we've been adding
support for metrics.
Some of those are a little
further along than others.
And Node.js I think
just entered in alpha,
if I remember correctly.
And so Node.js is going
to jump to full support
pretty quickly,
as well as Python.
.NET is under development
through our partnership with
Microsoft.
I'll get to that in a minute.
But they're going to be
handling development of .NET,
and I think they also have
a pretty strong interest
in Python and Node.
We have a huge number
of integrations,
far too many for me to list, and
certainly far too many for me
to have thrown into this
presentation at last minute.
But in general, we support
HTTP, gRPC, SQL, SQL clients,
MongoDB, most things that
you would expect to be there.
If you're using OpenCensus
and something isn't there
that you expect, you
can reach out to us.
Certainly we would love if
you made a pull request.
The whole goal of this project
is to get as many integrations
right into the main client
library so that people
can use them out of the box and
so that multiple vendors can
rely on and maintain the
same set of integrations.
Finally we have
exporters for a number
of really popular backends.
We've targeted our
functionality on OpenCensus
to always work for our two
reference backends for tracing
and metrics.
So Zipkin and Prometheus
support is always
there and always guaranteed.
We also support Jaeger,
SignalFx, Datadog, SolarWinds,
Instana, Amazon X-Ray,
and of course Stackdriver.
More and more backends are
being added all the time.
With the current
architecture of OpenCensus,
these exporters have
to be implemented
on a per-language basis.
And so some languages might
have more support while others
don't.
At the end of the
presentation, I'll
talk about a new
project we're working
on that's going to expand
that support even further.
OpenCensus also includes
some neat features.
So I mentioned analysis earlier.
So while it's mostly an
instrumentation project,
OpenCensus also gives
you some very quick ways
to understand what's
going on in your app.
The most prominent of those
is something we call Z-Pages.
So if you read "Hacker
News" a lot like I do,
there was a post one or two
days ago about debugging
and how we-- sort of some
of the Borg debugging
features used at Google.
One of the things that
was mentioned there,
and all the top-ranked
comments talked about
was these sort of Borg
status pages or Z-Pages.
And we provide these
through OpenCensus
to developers around the world.
These Z-Pages are basically
small web pages hosted
by the OpenCensus client
library on each node
of your application.
It shows basic
summaries of any RPCs
that have been going
through the system
as well as summaries of all
the stats on your system.
So it basically gives you
this little firehose view
for the instance of your
app that you're inspecting.
It's not necessarily as
useful as looking at something
like a distributed tracing
backend, like Stackdriver
Trace, which shows you
the end-to-end view.
These only show data
captured from a single node.
But if you think
that something's
wrong with a particular node,
or if your debugging process
starts with inspecting
a single node,
these Z-Pages are a great
place to go find that data.
One of the other
interesting features
we have is our work on the
W3C Trace-Context format.
So about a year and a half
ago, Google and Zipkin
started work on this
shared context propagation
format for distributed traces.
If you're familiar with
distributed tracing,
you might already
be aware of this.
But one of the
challenges in the space
is if you're using
different client libraries
or different
instrumentation frameworks,
traces still won't
always work together.
And so take an example of HTTP.
If I have service A,
service B, and service C,
in order to get a
distributed trace,
my distributed
tracing system has
to know that a single
request is correlated.
And so Zipkin uses, for example,
the B3 headers that basically
set a trace ID for this trace.
We started this
project with Zipkin,
and now a number
of other vendors,
including Microsoft and others,
to basically it will snap,
align everybody onto this same
context propagation format.
If you're using a
single-vendor system,
this probably doesn't
interest you as much.
But it's another way that
we're able to work better
with the community.
And it's really nice.
Finally, a neat
thing of OpenCensus
is just that you can use
multiple exporters at once.
So you can send traces and
metrics to as many backends
As you'd like.
For example, we
might have customers
who do some metrics
to Prometheus
and some go to Stackdriver,
or rather all go to both.
But if you're
either transitioning
between using different
vendors or you're
at some kind of
mixed-mode environment,
where different teams use
different systems, which
is actually relatively common,
OpenCensus will support that.
So if some company
gets acquired, comes
into your company, they're
using a different set of tools.
As long as you're
using OpenCensus,
you can send a telemetry
to all of those tools
and satisfy everybody,
which is really great.
All right so, once again, I'm
going to hop over to my demo.
So inside of this
application, we've
gone and already added
OpenCensus to the services.
So I'm going to pull up the
code for the product catalog
service.
There you are.
And so we're using OpenCensus
in the product catalog service
in order to capture
traces and metrics.
And most of the code
is captured here.
Just like I described, this
is a really nice scenario,
where you just basically
initialize the OpenCensus
service, choose an exporter,
and it captures effectively
everything you
want automatically.
In this init tracing function,
we register OpenCensus,
we tell it to use the
Stackdriver Exporter.
And we tell it to do that
for both tracing and stats,
and that's about it.
I think we also might mention
that we're using gRPC.
Beyond that, OpenCensus
will automatically go
and instrument gRPC.
It's going to capture
application-level metrics,
so things like latency
and packets-- sorry,
not packet size--
request size and queue
length and others,
and it's also
automatically going
to capture distributed
traces and propagate context.
And we saw that in the
Stackdriver Trace view.
And now I'm going to go try and
open the Metrics view to show
you the example of that.
Here we go.
I'm just going to
zoom out if I can.
So these are the metrics
captured by OpenCensus.
This is inside of Stackdriver.
This is not working
as I want it to.
And it's going to capture--
it's showing us the latency
of our application--
here we go-- the server latency.
And we're going to group this
by the different server methods.
So we can see the latency
across each server method.
And let's look at
the 95th percentile.
There we go.
Oh, I see the problem.
My screen is just
too zoomed to--
anyways, I can click on these.
If the screen was
higher resolution,
you would see the various
latencies, 95th percentile
latency, for each of the
different services contained
in this application.
So it's just with five
or six lines of code,
I'm now able to
get latency metrics
from all the different methods
handled on this single service.
Once I roll this out across all
the services in my application,
I now get to
understand the latency,
latency characteristics, of
every single endpoint attached
to every single service,
which is really, really nice.
And of course, we
already saw the traces.
But I also mentioned that
OpenCensus does custom metrics.
And so in addition to
automatically capturing
these metrics,
you as a developer
can go and add your own.
So what we had
added here, I think
to the cart service or
the checkout service,
was the ability to see how
many checkout requests are
going through the app.
And so I've done that here.
I'll just pull it up.
Apologies for the delay.
OpenCensus-- here we go.
And so in the code, which
I'll show you in a minute,
we're capturing the
number of items in a cart
when the cart is checked out.
And we can see the results here.
And the code for this
was pretty simple.
Where on earth is it?
Checkout service, there we go.
So we've registered
the view up above.
This is how we create
our new metric.
And then all we have to do
is scroll down to the code,
where we actually capture
it, which is a single line.
Here it is.
And with this
single line of code,
in addition to few
register the view,
I've been able to
capture a custom
metric for my application.
And I can send it to the backend
of my choice, which is great.
You can send this to Prometheus.
You can send this
to Stackdriver.
You can send this to
Datadog, wherever you really
want it to go.
And it's not much work.
It's both a great
developer experience.
If you're using
a single backend,
you can roll this out across
your entire application.
But it's a great developer--
it's an even better developer
experience if you're
working multiple backends
in a mixed-mode environment.
And so, like I mentioned
before, our goal of OpenCensus
is to make as much of this
automatic-- as automatic and as
easy as possible.
And I think with this
demo we've achieved that.
So I mentioned some really
interesting features
that are coming to OpenCensus.
The first is just
more integrations.
So today we've got a pretty big
list that we're quite proud of.
But as time goes on, we
want to add the ability
to get more traces and metrics
automatically from more
and more different stacks.
So, for example,
like today, I don't
think we support Google
Pub/Sub or Kafka.
We're going to be adding that.
We're going to be adding it
for as many technologies as
possible.
The next that's
really interesting
is this thing we call
the OpenCensus collector
service and smarter sampling.
So one of the challenges
of distributed tracing
today is that requests
come into your application,
they get traced,
and typically you
sample those that like a 1%
rate or something like that.
The problem with this is
that the average request
isn't very interesting.
If you think of the
average request that
goes to an e-commerce
backend or even to Google,
it's probably boring.
It sits around the
50th percentile.
If you're trying
to analyze latency,
it's not especially useful.
Typically you want to look
at requests that are either
correlated with errors or
requests that are slow,
in your 95th percentile latency,
99th percentile latency.
This is, of course,
very challenging,
because today when you make a
sampling decision on a request,
you usually do that
when it arrives.
And whatever request
comes in, you
don't really have a great way
of predicting whether it's
going to be slow or not.
What we're doing--
what we're trying to do
is build this service you can
deploy within your application.
Traces and metrics
from all of your nodes
are sent to that
service, and then we
can make the sampling
decision later.
And so the sampling decision
will be made on the service,
and then the traces will
be sent to your backend.
And so, for example,
you could configure it
to sample traces that have
something like 99th percentile
latency, 95th
percentile latency,
traces for requests that
are relatively uncommon,
basically traces that
are far more interesting.
As an application
developer, this
means you're actually getting
actionable data instead
of spending all of
your time and money
on collecting traces that
are, frankly, not that useful.
And so this is like
a big, big thing
that OpenCensus is
going to provide soon.
Next, after that,
is providing support
for client applications.
So one of the challenges
of tracing solutions today,
or at least some of them,
including Stackdriver,
is that they don't support--
they don't really give you
true end-to-end latency.
You can see the latency of an
operation that occurs inside
of your web application or
inside of your data center
or inside of Google
Cloud, for example.
But typically you're
not getting visibility
into the actual
latency perceived
by a client, whether that client
is a frontend web application
or that client is like
an Android or iOS app.
And so we're going
to be adding support
for those in OpenCensus.
So we can capture traces,
all the way from your user's
interaction with some
of their software,
all the way to going to
your back and then back.
And so instead of seeing
that a user interaction took
200 milliseconds and wondering
why your customers say
that your app is
slow, you can actually
see that it's taking two seconds
because of some kind of network
issue between their
app, some iOS app
and your backend application.
And finally we, of
course, are looking
to expand the list
of partners that we
work with for OpenCensus.
And to that end,
certainly this is
sort of the big players
in the ecosystem.
There are a ton of other
contributors, typically just
open source
contributors not working
for a particular company.
OpenCensus, of course,
started at Google.
We are the main contributor.
We effectively run the project.
But in the last few
weeks or months,
we've also gotten
a lot of support
from Microsoft,
SignalFx, and Pivotal.
Pivotal, in particular,
right now is
maintaining a fork
of OpenCensus that--
basically a .NET copy
of OpenCensus Java.
And we're there working with
Microsoft right now in turning
that into an official
OpenCensus for .NET library.
SignalFx we've been
talking to a lot
about co-developing
that OpenCensus service.
And they've made some other
contributions to the library,
so we're really
excited about that.
SolarWinds, Datadog, and Instana
have all provided exporters.
And with any luck,
they'll move up the list
and become core contributors.
But we're also just
really excited to have
them involved to any degree.
We are always looking to
grow the tent for OpenCensus,
whether you are a individual
open source developer--
and there are many, many of
them working on the project,
as well--
or you work at another
vendor in this space.
We're really excited to work
with anyone, like really.
And so we're really
proud of the progress
we've made in a fairly
short period of time
in attracting some big names
of groups that share our vision
and want to make
tracing and metrics
and just generally observability
more accessible to everyone.
And so hopefully when
we show this next year,
it will be an even bigger list.
All right, I think that's it.
Thank you very much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much
for staying, yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]